[Música]
quero começar com uma aposta
eu aposto que vocês já tiveram essa aula
sabe aquela que a gente aprende que não
pode ficar um monte de tempo no banho
que não pode esquecer a mão ali na
descarga que você tem que fechar a
torneira da pia enquanto escova os
dentes porque a água no planeta vai
acabar seja tiveram né
eu tive até hoje eu escovo dente com
sede e se você é pai ou mãe muito
provavelmente você já recebeu um
bilhetinho da escola do seu filho
andando levar uma garrafa pet
aí você que é super participativo é a
aula de reciclagem chega cansado do
trabalho mas vai no supermercado comprar
a tal da garrafa pet esvaziar todo o
conteúdo na pia que nem bebe
refrigerante e manda pra escola
dias depois o que você recebe um
cinzeiro de garrafa pet um porta-lápis
de garrafa pet
um coelho da páscoa de garrafa pet indo
verde porque tudo que seu filho faz é
lindo e aí o coelhinho vai lá pra
instante da sua sala e fica lá meses até
aqui num dia de faxina
o coelhinho verde alienígena
misteriosamente desaparece e aquele lixo
que até poderia ter sido reciclado
agora cheio de cola de purpurina e
lantejoula segue a sua saga de passar
500 anos embaixo da terra 500 não 499
que ele passou uma temporada na sua casa
muito bem porque as escolas fazem isso
vocês vão me dizer oh é a gente tem que
salvar o planeta
tá louca
tem uma boa e uma má notícia para vocês
vou começar pela boa que hoje é dia de
festa planeta terra não precisa ser
salvo a natureza conhece a fórmula
perfeita para manter a vida no planeta
faz isso há bilhões de anos
a má notícia é que nós talvez não
estejamos assim tão garantidos nos
últimos 500 milhões de anos a terra
passou cinco vezes por processos de
extinção em massa incluindo a extinção
destas belezinhas há 65 milhões de anos
especialistas analisando as taxas de
extinção causadas por desmatamento e
destruição de habitats afirmam que o
planeta terra já entrou no seu sexto
processo de extinção em massa e
diferente das vezes anteriores que foram
causadas por fenômenos físicos naturais
como glaciações asteróides e erupções
vulcânicas
esse evento de extinção que é único na
sua magnitude é causado pelas ações de
uma única espécie
adivinha lá o ator scharmer que é um
pesquisador do mit criador da teoria eo
tem uma uma pergunta que eu gosto muito
porque nós coletivamente
produzimos resultados que
individualmente ninguém quer
vocês acham que existe saída pra nós
eu acho que sim o homem é um ser
extraordinariamente inteligente mas como
gosta de dizer o suíço era bush gates
criador da agricultura se em troca
enquanto nem achar que ele é o ser mais
inteligente do planeta muito pouco vai
mudar
o homem tem que entender que ele é um
ser inteligente que faz parte de um
sistema inteligente
a resposta sempre teve na natureza os
ecossistemas mantêm a vida na terra com
abundância de energia sem desperdício há
bilhões de anos
a natureza é capaz de fabricar
superfícies como as conchas dos moluscos
que são mais duras que a nossa cerâmica
que é produzida com alta tecnologia
ou as teias das aranhas que são cinco
vezes mais resistentes do que aço e tudo
isso feito em processos silenciosos
a baixa temperatura sem produção de
resíduos tóxicos às nossas crianças
precisam passar por um novo processo de
alfabetização
as nossas crianças precisam aprender
essa inteligência essa tecnologia
as nossas crianças precisam aprender os
princípios que regem os ecossistemas
vivos e a esse novo processo de
alfabetização o extraordinário físico
fritjof capra e sua equipe da califórnia
chamaram de alfabetização ecológica diz
jucá para que não é exagero dizer que a
sobrevivência da humanidade vai depender
da nossa capacidade de entender
corretamente os princípios da ecologia e
da vida chega do caso nossas crianças
produzindo o ecofolia falando de
ecologia no discurso de medo e culpa as
crianças não são responsáveis pelos
nossos erros
as crianças nascem conectadas são os
processos educativos que tem
desconectadas crianças e produzido uma
educação que é esvaziada de sentido
mas não precisa ser assim pode ser
diferente crianças podem construir um
futuro a partir de uma nova lógica das
partes e do todo dos objetos para as
relações da quantidade para a qualidade
do ego proeco à educação do futuro é uma
educação sistêmica é uma educação
relacional é uma educação integral seja
pararam pra pensar que as escolas
deveriam ser responsáveis por produzir
parte do seu alimento agricultura outro
é uma das maiores vilãs da crise
ambiental que a gente vive
mas não precisa ser assim e se existe um
jeito de plantar alimentos em contaminar
o solo sem enfrentar nós mesmos gerando
água capturando o co2 trazendo de volta
à biodiversidade perdida
regenerando e as crianças podem aprender
esse jeito as crianças nas escolas podem
plantar o seu próprio alimento
as crianças podem preparar o seu
alimento e as crianças podem compostar
os resíduos que sobram entendendo que a
gente pode fechar ciclos que não precisa
existir lixo para jogar fora aliás onde
ao lado de fora do planeta
as escolas poderiam ter banheiros
compostáveis banheiros secos construídos
pelas próprias crianças e assim eles
aprenderem que a gente não precisa
contaminar o nosso bem mais precioso que
é a água
isso tudo pode ser feito a baixos custos
usando as técnicas da perna cultura em
ambientes rurais e ambientes urbanos em
grandes e em pequenos espaços
as escolas precisam se organizar como
exemplos vivos de comunidades humanas
sustentáveis locais onde as crianças
possam aprender os princípios ecológicos
vivendo a gente possa devolver para as
crianças a compreensão de processos
básicos da onde vem a comida o que
acontece quando eu aperto e descarga
as escolas precisam ser lugares onde as
crianças aprendam a não colocar em risco
as chances das gerações futuras
as escolas precisam ser lugares de
conexão de conexão das crianças com elas
mesmas com os outros e com o planeta uma
educação fora das fileiras seriadas das
salas de aula até mesmo fora dos muros
da escola
a essa altura do campeonato você deve
estar perguntando nossa ela está
sugerindo da gente educada todo mundo
junto
plantando e colhendo que nem índio
exatamente e usando toda a informação e
toda a tecnologia disponível porque o
mundo não é feito de ouro como gostam de
nos fazer pensar
o mundo é feito de s muitas verdades
muitos caminhos muitas possibilidades e
os povos antigos chegam parte dessa
verdade que é o sentimento de totalidade
de conexão de unidade um sentimento que
muitos de nós às vezes buscam até mesmo
sem saber durante uma vida inteira
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]